he's just laughing and he's just
starting over one of ways hi guys so
back by popular demands I am playing
five nights at freddys turn for you I
don't think this really needs an
introduction other than I know you've
been waiting for it so do enjoy I know
they've got all new animatronics in this
new game and apparently it's supposed to
be ten times scarier which makes me feel
bad good not good
walking today
that means but most importantly they're
all some kind of criminal database so
they can detect a predator a mile away
and we should be paying them to guard
you now that being said no new system is
about it kinks you're only the second
guard to work at that location the first
guy finished his week but complained
about conditions we switched him over to
the day shift so I wonder where the
station family is where's my son that
certain character seemed to move around
at night and even attempted to get into
his office
now we know that should be impossible
that restaurant should be always on
earth so while our engineers don't
really have an explanation whether the
working theory is that the robots
whatever is
overnight close so when it gets quiet
they think they're in a long room so
then they go try to find where the
people are in this case that's your
office so our temporary solution is that
there's a music box over by the prize
counter and it's rigged to be wound up
remotely all right every once in a while
watch over the prize counter video game
is 30 seconds it doesn't seem to affect
all of the animatronics but it does
affect one of them which one is not you
think there may be a minor glitch in the
system something about robots an
endoskeleton without its costume on and
wanting to stuff you want to sue so hey
we've given you any of these pretty
fanfare head wander back out you may
have noticed there are no doors for you
to close hey you have a line and even
though your flashlight you're running
out of power that's good to know
oh okay don't leave me okay they're all
there it's fine
this little guy I like his balloons I
got to admit the rooms that a lot more
cool this time and these vents are
totally creepy
I don't like how there's the messed up
robots
are they the old ones why they just left
there in the middle of rooms in this box
has one gone
no they're okay they're okay it's nice
that you can look at the security
cameras for as long as you want and the
battery isn't gonna die which makes me
feel so good oh wow look it's cupcake I
want a cupcake
give me the cupcake
has one gone okay I think one is gone
it's fine just keep this wound up good
Oh uh-huh there is
he's just jamming on the guitar that's
fine that's not scary
oh okay and now he is kissing the camera
he just misses me it's fine not scary
seeing my last playthrough it wasn't me
who was scared I'm such a liar with me
that was good but shamina was more
scared so yeah what's that noise it
sounds creepily like the TARDIS
it actually sounds like the TARDIS is
going to me it's not because hello are
you about to go and depend on you I saw
you're doing that what is that noise
oh hello oh you're so creepy and then
it's just you the bad
that's my disguise
anyone whoa this is gonna be easy
absolutely totally what's the time oh
yeah this is gonna be easy actually
yeah
is she coming
Gary that was so easy she just came to
give me a cupcake that was all I don't
see what is so scary about this game I
feel ready brave right now okay I'm
going on the tube hello first my prepare
them they are retrofitting them with
some of the newer technology is so ugly
a whole direction and make them super
can Franklin one shouldn't be able to
walk around but if they do the whole
Freddy head trick should work on them
too so what
yes oh yeah I'm not sure if undesirable
the complaint for these seconds oh my
god okay anyway I sure won't be a
problem okay
missing you already right
what
did you hear that what what that male
kids gone oh my god is he a robot as
well the kid is he's supposed to be is
he supposed to be one of them
it's either one that that listens to the
music box oh my god where is the kick on
no not more TARDIS noises although China
set off me I guess a little bit
I remember you I was terrified please go
away
what the hell I'm passionate bash like
this one oh my god okay this is gonna be
hard right now I totally regret saying
it's easy I didn't mean it Jesus happy
oh my god hey what do you want me to do
like am I supposed to why is that little
boy in the van what this what this save
me what do you think that I'm his entity
okay let's try that again I will look
out for foxy this time a bit more I
don't understand what little boys doing
is he can hurt me as well or is he just
kind of trapped in there is he like me a
victim or is he like every other thing
in this place trying to kill me
why [ __ ] see all the time why do this to
me
I wish we could just be friends okay I'm
good it's all good but it's a it's a
little boy there or is he gone
they're boys they're holding the
balloons exactly where it should be
ah I didn't think I get jumpscared that
quickly I thought I'd just get through
Mike - its cookies it at night one I'm
so okay they're still there is it but
still going
see this one whatever it was a chicken
or a duck or ever when did it become a
[ __ ] and why is that okay for kids
parties look at those hot pants I would
not have the guts to wear them
Oh God
I don't like it when they cut off hello
okay I wish you I wish you could listen
to him playing for anyway
whereas Fox it is at least before I knew
where he was and I could always check
the cat and not I did a very good job
because he killed me but still hi hi
hello
go away what is wrong with this kid
oh I don't like it yes we goosebumps
he's like creepier than the actual
animatronic stupid people
hello you Oh God keep going keep going
keep going
why did not the music but somebody let
the music box okay hey I don't know what
to do with you I don't know how to
entertain you I don't know what I'm
supposed to do I'm stuck the last time I
did this I got caught by fancy so I
don't know what to do okay stoner
oh hello maybe that is the noise foxy
but I swear the noise has come before
and foxy
Oh foxy please don't hurt me because I
need to I used to do the me the Box I'm
very sorry please don't have a fizz I
had please ahead please so happy
please I'll have it is thank you
he listened to me he like ok my head
come by say hi and still there
why you still that
I don't know what I'm doing I think
you've already nervous my hand is it
butts hi Oh foxy go away no one likes
you
and this is not fair
no don't laugh why did I say I would be
this again why don't I do this all for
you oh hey you hey you hey you hey you
what what W&E hello what is this is this
how they see me in their little
electronic mind okay
how cool is this
following the little floating man this
is so strange what they've done are they
turning me into an animatronic oh look
oh it's like I'm in security numbers and
there's blood on the floor now I'm very
confused I'm just gonna stop trying to
understand things oh is that
but I'm going to leave it there because
I'm very confused about that I mean I
thought that I was still playing but now
I did die I just turned into some weird
walking animatronic I don't know thing
anyway please give this a thumbs up if
you enjoyed and let me know if you want
to see more of this I know you probably
will let me know if you played this and
how many nights you got to have loved
video evening by the room Oh wasting
every just hit the light on I want to
see a solid